One video per deck, no more unhealthy
obsessions. Ugu was peak, we are not
topping that. Or so I thought. Past few
days I caught myself daydreaming at
work, canceling arrangements to
playtest, and staying up late replying
to YouTube comments. I even shopped for
all kinds of props, all for this one
deck. And I don't even feel bad about
it. I mean, based on my experience so
far and your reactions, we really did
stumble onto something special this
time. Where Ugu had hundreds of
possibilities, Yu-mi has infinite. So
today we are going to dive a bit deeper
into the deck, talk about some of the
card choices that were suggested. I made
some pretty major changes since the last
video, thanks to playtesting. Also,
there are some hilarious suggestions.
Yeah, I'm giddy here just thinking about
them. We'll start fairly based,
relatively speaking, and we will get
more and more unhinged as the video goes
on. And there's some pretty wild stuff.
We're getting into trade wars,
franchising. We'll start with the more
general questions and deck tech stuff
though, so you can choose to bail
whenever if you feel like it's getting
too much. But firstly, the most
important. People say I'm pronouncing
Yu-mi wrong, but I'm not. I mean, Yu-mi
is my commander, how can I pronounce the
name of my commander wrong? It's
pronounced Yu-mi. Yeah. I I've always
said Yu-mi. Yeah. Mhm. Next up, people
are bringing up how similar this deck is
to the otter from the game Root. I did
some research and it's amazing. Yeah. I
I honestly, I had no idea before, but
that's what it is. It's freaking
adorable. And also, I just want to
mention how crazy supportive people are
in the comments. Like, people are
genuinely excited about this. And sure,
people are generally pretty nice, but
really, this is nothing like what I've
seen before. And the thing is, yes, this
deck sounds awesome, but with this I
feel more driven to make sure that this
deck doesn't just sound good, but
actually works for those who end up
spending the time and money to put this
together. And that's what this video is
going to do, at least in the first half.
First of all, on the macro level, there
is some concern that this deck will not
work. Partially because Yu-mi is not
very pushed compared to a lot of the
other commanders. She's mono white, the
ability says once a turn, and actually
when I first built the deck, I
completely missed the on your turn part,
and that's a huge nerf. I was actually
so disappointed, almost gave up on the
deck then and there, and I probably
would have with any other commander, but
Yume is just so different. The way we're
playing with the deck, like with our
hands revealed the entire time, means
that the entire table is, at least in
theory, capable of thoroughly evaluating
how strong we are at any point, and that
will dictate whether they want to work
with us or burn down the shop. Yes, this
is an inherent part of multiplayer, but
never to this extent. Yume is
self-balancing. Just imagine this
version of Yume with this hand. Would
you make any deals or buy anything?
Probably not. So, it's entirely possible
that in a group with decent threat
evaluation, that Yume Pro Max over here
has the same win rate as Yume. Now, this
understanding will come up a lot in our
game plan and card evaluation. People
have also been concerned about our win
condition. How do we win the game? Well,
eventually we have to close shop and
turn on one opponent. It being just one
opponent depends a lot on how we manage
the game. We have to try to navigate the
game state so that we are never the
biggest threat, not now and not in the
foreseeable future. This can be
difficult and can lead to some truly
bizarre plays. For example, when an
opponent raised concern about a fair
well in my hand, I reminded him that he
has the option to just buy it and use it
to exile only graveyards. We want our
opponents to focus on killing other
scarier threats while thinking, often
times correctly, that they have a 60%
chance against us, if not more.
And in the end, we are going to come out
and snatch victory from their jaws four
times out of 10.
Yeah, that's right. What did you expect?
A lot of the charm of this deck comes
from the complete transparency. You
don't want a high win rate with this
deck. In fact, ideally, you want it to
be just below 25%, and when it is, bring
a spreadsheet, bring a calculator, and
make sure everyone knows about it. Now,
I know this sounds very idealistic and
is probably not that easy to do, but
what's important is that we have this
game plan in mind so that we can get
closer and closer to it by adjusting how
we play and our card choices. And the
best part is the process is a blast.
Okay, enough of this abstract
philosophical crap. Let's move on to
some specific examples. Starting simple,
play testing has shown me that we need
more white mana sources.
Yeah, because when we sell something,
the colorless cost is partly covered, so
that we can play multiple spells a turn,
and that means we need often times four
white mana, sometimes even five, because
a lot of these spells are pretty color
intensive. So, I have to swap some of my
colorless utility lands for white ones.
And next up, I had to overhaul the
security team. I started off with a
bunch of spot removals, because during
that period I played against a lot of
Voltron decks and decks with lighter
board presence, and I guess I was in
that mental space. But in further play
testing, I played against more of those
green decks who build and continue to
develop a significant board state. And
to those players, I am scary. Like they
would, you know, buy things, play
normally, but but the first chance they
get, they turn on me and try to go for
the kill. And in retrospect, that's
pretty obvious, because I'm holding two
board wipes in my hand, and other
players, as far as they're concerned,
might have zero. But these board wipes
really are pretty important to our game
plan, and is one of white's biggest
strengths. So, instead of single target
removals and these one-sided board
wipes, I'm now playing more
instant-speed ones. At first, I skipped
them because I can only do business on
my turn, and these can kill you mate.
But I think the versatility more than
makes up for it. Because remember, not
everything's for sale. When we reveal
our hands, we separate what is for sale
and what isn't. Now, these board wipes
can be either, depending on the
situation. With these in hand, our
opponents have to think twice about
attacking us, because they will risk
losing their board. And this is also why
I'm deciding not to play cards like
Everybody Lives. I even cut to Teferi's
Protection, because we want there to be
consequences. And these protection
spells are far less powerful when it's
not a surprise. And for the remaining
board wipes, I want them to be at least
modal, with some room for negotiation.
But another problem is, again, Yuumi
might die from these. And also, Yuumi
can just die from collateral damage.
People don't usually target her, but
when it happens, it's very awkward, cuz
then I need one turn to cast Yuumi, and
we can't open shot until the next turn.
So, with that experience, I decided to
also add in some flash enablers, most
notably Winding Canyons and Purphoros,
God of the Forge and yeah, it may seem
narrow, but the way it changes how you
play Yuumee is completely worth it.
Also, we do have a few other humans, so
that could be relevant. But with all
that said, it doesn't change the fact
that when we have two or even three
board wipes in our hand, we can feel
pretty oppressive and being oppressive
is the last thing you want to do. So,
once again, be creative with how you use
the board wipes. Not every board wipe
has to be destroying everything. We can
cast these planeswalkers to make tokens.
We can use Final Showdown as a
protection spell. Everything is
negotiable. To take this even further, I
decided to include a Scroll Rack along
with more shuffle effects. This way we
can actually send away cards that people
find threatening. Things are so much
easier when people know that you are
sincere about keeping a healthy
relationship until the last possible
moment. Okay, let's now talk about a few
other options that I'm not taking. The
first one being stacks cards. The idea
is that you stacks your opponents so
they can't play spells, so they're
forced to buy your goods. Now, that
sounds good in theory, but again, it
will be oppressive. And I'm not talking
about this for the sake of my
playgroup's experience. I don't care
about that. But being oppressive and
having too much control on the game is
like the opposite of what we want to do
here. And it doesn't take much for
people to realize that they can just
burn down the shop altogether and be
done with this nonsense. Another one of
the most common suggestions is Wedding
Ring. Yeah, it seems super flavorful.
I'm afraid to play it. I have yet to
test it, but the reason is because like
I mentioned in the other video, I don't
want continuous group hug effects
because imagine the opponent I married
to is ahead in the game and now I'm in a
dilemma cuz I want to draw cards to be
able to keep up, but then when I draw
cards, I'm further enabling them. So,
I'm still being very careful with these.
And in the comment section, there are
some pretty amazing card choice
suggestions and a lot of them I've
taken. And here I will explain my
thought process behind some of them.
Well, first of all, like I said earlier,
I've been trying
the kind of products I carry. I don't
want them to be just board wipes and
removals. Giacomoseia mentioned the
Sentry. Yeah, this is exactly what I
want. Similarly, Teo, mentioned by Adam
Tom, is another kind of unique product
with such a special effect that we can
add to our inventory. To that, the
Legend of Young Chen and Vault 13. They
don't do anything too special, but just
the combined utility among the chapters
make them excellent value-filled
packages. Another sweet call is Victory
Chimes. Well, at first, I did consider
this card, but Vush Pow was the one who
pointed out that I can literally just
give a mana to my opponent to help them
buy my product. You know, if the economy
gets rough. And also just the political
implications, give me one mana now, I'll
give you one on your turn. Another card
I decided to add myself was Reverse the
Sands. Yeah, with all the implications
of this card, I'm not sure if it's going
to help or hurt me more, but either way,
it's going to be glorious. Okay, now
moving on to cards that not only do
work, but also kind of change how we
play. The first one is Lauren. Yes, it's
a decent removal, but the tap ability
gives our store the option to do
promotions in the future. Yeah, one card
isn't enough of an incentive, we can do
a bundle deal. Excellent idea. Thanks,
Phil. So, as you can see, we are moving
from individual card choices to also
tweaking how we play the deck. Just a
quick reminder, the way I'm doing it now
is whenever Yumaz is on the battlefield,
I reveal my hand to everyone, and I will
separate what is for sale and what
isn't. People can take a look and make
an offer. I will try to always take an
offer, and when there are multiples, I
will choose based on several factors
like the board state or how much they're
willing to pay. Whenever a deal is made,
I press a special button and a message
plays. And yeah, that's it for the
essential aspects of running this deck.
I try to keep it as simple and as
neutral as possible, but I also can't
play just like an NPC without any
judgment because in that way, the person
with the most mana, who is likely
already ahead, will just snowball thanks
to our help. We we try to be fair to
everyone, but we have to use some of our
own judgment. With that said, once your
group becomes more familiar and
accepting of your play style, we can add
more rules. If you're familiar with the
game Avalon, think of it like this. When
I teach new players to play, it's always
just good and evil, but once they become
more familiar with the rules and game
and the dynamics, we introduce Merlin.
And after that, all the other
characters. We gradually increase the
complexity. And in this case, something
we can do is preorders. Yeah, why not? I
mean, you can have your hand always
revealed, and you only cast Yume when
someone commits to buying something.
Sometimes early game people are busy
developing their own board, so they have
no extra mana. This way, we won't risk
opening up, paying for all the overhead,
and not make any sales. At least we're
making one. And usually one leads to
another. And also, Dustinggu mentioned a
couple of special cards for VIP
customers only. Now, I understand this
as kind of like a membership club. If
you spend enough, you get access to
special goods like life swapping.
Emerald cool? Yeah, just have a
threshold like spending, you know, eight
mana on buying things lifetime, and you
get access. You can bring these little
cards to hand out. That would be
amazing. Also, another sweet
interpretation of this is taking
requests before the game. Like, if
you're a platinum customer, yeah, why
not? What card do you want? I will add
it to the deck. Like, the Goblin deck
wants a Gauntlet of Might? Yeah, I can
do that. The Elf deck wants an
Armageddon? Well, all I can say is the
customer is always right. That's pretty
awesome. You can just bring a sideboard
of random utility cards and symmetrical
effects for people to choose from. But
Gato also pointed out, yeah, while you
can have VIP customers, there should
also be a blacklist. And that brings up
my favorite part, tariffs. Yeah, get on
our bad side and everything is going to
cost you more. I once imposed a
Trinisphere tariff on my friend Jared.
Everything he buys will cost a minimum
of three mana. Even if the card didn't
cost that much, he had to tap three to
buy anything. He did not win that game.
Neither did I, because he decided to
turn the trade war into an actual war.
But I'm sure he learned his lesson. An
alternative to that is having fixed
prices for everything and everyone.
Literally, just be a shop. Now, the
downsides, there are many downsides like
I mentioned earlier, you might help the
winner. And also, there's not much
flexibility. You can't play favoritism,
and you can't even do trade wars
anymore. But the upside is you can bring
a sticker gun to every game, and just
sticker everything. Yeah, and once
you're bored of that, you can start
doing discounts. Sounds like fun. And
with that, you can use Fail Winx's
amazing suggestion. Just turn the deck
into an NPC. Yeah, whenever you have
three players, use it as the fourth
player. I'm not sure how well that
works. Like you're going to have to have
a set of rules dictating who can buy
things and when. And again, to avoid the
king-making situation. But that sounds
like something fun to figure out. And
finally, my favorite suggestion. I was
actually annoyed that I didn't come up
with this myself. And that is Jonathan's
Assault Suit. There's actually so much
you can do with this because now you're
adding another layer to selling
creatures. Cuz not only can your
opponents buy the ETB ability, if they
pay enough, you can send the creature
over to help them attack. But that's not
the fun part. The truly unhinged play is
sending Yumi around. Now, remember the
horrors of seeing a Nurse Joy in every
Pokémon Center and the same shopkeeper
in every Poké Mart? Yumi is doing that.
We are franchising. You want to open a
shop, too? Oh, just sign these papers
and get ready to welcome your first
customer, which is probably me. Or we
can even have a bank, like some kind of
mana charge system. Help me pay for
Assault Suit on my turn, and when I give
you Yumi, I will repay three mana, maybe
even with interest. And now that we're
going the ways of capitalism and
conglomerates, why not just go all the
way? Let's get real money involved. My
friend Deacon brought up the possibility
of just dumping your trade binder, the
white section of course, into Yumi. And
your opponents can just pay for the
cards with money. And one mana of course
for the assist trigger. But yeah, then
they get the card for the game and also
afterwards. I'm sure people will be a
little more incentivized to purchase
cards if they can win them the EDH game
they're currently playing in. And this
is crazy work. Yeah, the possibilities
are actually endless. I love this. And
everything I'm saying here is just tip
of the iceberg. There's so much for you
to explore with your playgroup. I'm half
hoping that I won't have to make a third
video about this, but I also kind of
want to because that would mean I get
even more amazing suggestions for this
deck. And honestly, these are so fun to
read. So please keep it up and I will
keep the giveaway going. I'm going to
keep this very simple. Giveaway rules
are in the descriptions. We are giving
away awesome Kakapopo products, but if
you don't want to wait or rely on random
chance, you can visit their site, check
out what they have, and use my discount
code. But more importantly, the winners
from my Nephalem video. We have Lord
Ocram trying to create an infinite loop
here. And Narwhal Repellent who
suggested Dragonfire Blade. Please make
a comment or see below for my contact
information. Oh, also, a few of the
previous winners haven't contacted me
yet. Now, there's no rush. I'm here for
the foreseeable future. But if you see
this, I have a full list of winners down
below in the descriptions. Check if you
are there. And that's it for this video.
Thank you for joining me on this
journey. I don't think this is the end.
I will continue to test you may and
yeah, whatever I come up with, I will
keep you updated, and I hope you can do
the same because this is awesome. Thank
you. See you.